so help me God Chris if you ruined my
relationship I'll kill you I feel like
I'm for the most part a pretty pretty
honest don't have too many skeletons in
the closet I think he might be a little
annoyed
maybe pissed off a bit with this secret
it was really hard to think of a secret
I didn't know like how you know where
where to kind of steer that boat I feel
like you know a lot of secrets about max
I feel like he knows a lot of my secrets
and that's what's scary less of a secret
but more of a sneak I'm a little nervous
that my secret is gonna be meaner well
he's gonna go first
no we're gonna Rochambeau do you want to
like hold my hands like like Oprah all
right so when we started dating okay we
were at square we were living in LA
right but you're from LA
remember that internship I had where I
was like so I was working two days a
week internship and I would drive up to
LA so this is maybe like a month and a
half into us Dave
so it turns out I was actually staying
at your house your parents yeah yeah
you're basically I was staying at your
house two nights a week as soon as I was
old enough to like like girls and think
girls are like pretty all right like did
this weird thing in my head where I like
every time I saw a girl that I thought
was really pretty I like make kind of
like making a list but it was like I
would I would just be like
I would blow a little kiss to them like
front whether it's on TV or on the
street or anything I would get and a
little kiss and then in my head that
marked that person so that when I went
to heaven they would be there my biggest
secret is that I drink out of it that's
it let's go don't you have a what a
secret of telling something cute and fun
oh so the cute won't hurt your feelings
I like pranking people what you
obviously know you felt me thanking
people sometimes but and you know this
I've told you this in the past you have
a tendency to like talk during your
sleep you waking up in the mill the
night and you start off with like
coherent sentences that start getting
like really weird like yesterday I went
to the mom goes I'm just mumbling and
it's been really sad yesterday I went to
the mall or whatever you need to start
off with like coherent phrases that turn
into I don't know what it sounds like
you're possessed or something but I've
been recording you and like putting them
up onto a snapchat story but it's like
an inside joke between my friends and I
so you've gotten me a bunch of more
followers on snapchat
six months six months are you kidding me
with my with my ex-boyfriend we went up
to my elementary school roof in the
middle of the night and we had sex on
the roof and no one knows about that yes
yep no I do
yeah cool that's dou Sooners aren't
cooking dinner I will drop something
on the floor and I just put it on your
plate
but the reason I don't feel that bad
about it is I know you would eat it
anyway on that Billy goes it's weird
that he was in my room right like the
room I grew up in while I was at college
that's very weird
I kind of wish at Mile is a little cuter
I just feel ashamed I feel a lot of
shame really should I'm a little bit
like curious about like what this new
thing that's been taught in my life
which is that apparently I sleep talk
and apparently there's video of me doing
it just now that I've heard yours secret
I'm I'm extremely upset have you ever
even made you the person you are today
is Joe
[Music]